[Générique d'intro]
Rends-toi, Lex Luthor !
Oh
Eh oui ! Je savais que t'allais venir me chercher.
Et j'ai tout prévu Superman !
Mais j'tai retrouvé malgré le fait que tu t'caches dans un immeuble en plomb.
Ça aussi je l'ai prévu.
Le seul immeuble auquel tu ne pouvais pas voir au travers était forcément ma cachette.
Tu avais prévu de...
Mais tu pouvais pas...
Arrête de faire le perroquet !
(rires)
Je t'ai envoyé des mails et tu m'as jamais répondu.
Hahaha ça aussi je l'avais prévu, je savais que t'allais passer par ce chemin, je t'ai mis une tapette !
Tu as un cerveau malade Lex.
Je vais t'emmener en taule
Et je m’échapperai comme d'habitude.
Alors je te rattraperai.
Tu sais, le mieux ce serait que tu restes avec moi, tu restes tout le temps avec moi.
Parce que je fais rien qu'des bêtises, quand t'es pas là.
Allez capture-moi, emmène-moi dans ta Forteresse de Solitude
On vivra tous les deux, je te ferai à manger et le ménage.
Je... Je comprends pas...
Tu vois à travers les murs ! Ca veut dire que tu vois à travers mes vêtements.
T'aimes bien ce que tu vois ?
T'aimes bien ?
Regarde, regarde...
Je fais du step.
C'est en acier hein, c'est en acier, c'est comme toi !
Tu sais, moi je vois pas à travers les murs mais..
En tous cas, je peux que... à travers tes vêtements, que tu es bien bâti.
Est-ce que je peux t'appeler Kalel ?
Oh !
Tu as ma Kryptonite Superman.
Bah ça alors... !
Lex Luthor qui est mort...
Qui a pu faire ça Superman ?
Je... Je sais pas du tout... Chais pas...
C'est étrange.
On dirait qu'il a explosé à l'intérieur.
Ouais, ouais c'est... c'est euh... c'est bizarre !
C'est comme si un marteau piqueur l'avait vio...
Wow !
Qu'est ce que c'est ça ?
Qu'est ce que c'est ça ? C'est quoi cette matière verte et gluante ?
Je sais pas... je sais pas... Je vais y aller moi !
C'est dingue, on dirait...
Non !?...
Je suis seul
Euh... Essuyez...
[Générique de fin]